well the verdict's still being read out
in the court behind me but at nine
minutes past ten local the judge said
the defendant imguard f is found guilty
of aiding the murder of more than 10 000
people and five cases of attempted
murder in stuttoff concentration camp
just to give you some background to this
case she is a 97 year old who when she
was 18 worked at stuchhof concentration
camp which is near Gdansk in Poland she
worked as a secretary for the SS
commander and She's accused of basically
aiding the killing of more than 10 000
people in in the fact that she had
according to the prosecution knowledge
of what was going on in that camp and to
give you an idea of what was going on in
that camp more than 65 000 people died
uh Institute of concentration camp some
were gassed shot starved worked to death
it was incredibly cruel place in Winter
they were left with very little clothes
very little food made to work very long
hours a few hours sleep one of the
former people who were held in there
told us that at night people often died
in their beds to the point that every
day they had to check all of the bunk
beds and bring the bodies to the
crematorium and that the fires the
furnaces that burned the bodies went 24
hours a day but there were so many
bodies that they just couldn't keep up
with the demand so imguard ferchner was
accused of knowing about this she said
really very little throughout this trial
at the end
of the hearings she said that she was
sorry about what had happened in
stuttoff Camp but really denied any
responsibility for what was going on she
claimed that she didn't know that is
something that survivors have challenged
we went to strohoff to see where she
worked and her office actually overlooks
the camp and they were questioning how
could she not know what was happening to
the thousands of people that were being
kept there how could she not smell the
smoke from the fires at the bodies were
being burned how could she not see the
rows of prisoners starved and frightened
walking in front of her window every
morning now the judge has made this
verdict but it's an important case
because this is likely to be one of the
last cases that we hear in these Nazi
trials because over the last few years
Germany has been trying to bring former
Nazis to justice but because of their
ages and as I said imguard is 97 many of
them have become too old so she is
likely to be the last case which is
tried in these Nazi trials